something trying to actively access an
object. An object is the passive entity. It's
whatever is being accessed. It can be another problem.
We've gone through a brief overview of the reference monitor concept,
the implementation of which is the security kernel.
the implementation of which is the security kernel, and this is one of the
components within the TCB, the trusted computing base.
These next few slides are where we delve into each of these pieces in a little more detail.
Now, we have to start with, of course, what's the subject versus what's an object?
And the subject is the active entity. It's a person or it's a process. It's something
trying to actively access an object. And an object is the passive entity. It's
whatever is being accessed. It can be another process. It could be a database,
a sharepoint site, a hard drive, could even be a building or a system.
This is the object. And the reference monitor concept is this whole idea that we want to be
able to mediate or control a subject's access to an object, control and mediate that access
based on a set of rules. And all this is logged and monitored. This is the reference monitor
concept. And of course, for this concept to be effective, we have to implement it.
And so a security kernel is the implementation of the reference monitor concept.
And a security kernel can be anything. It can be hardware, firmware, software,
anything that's actually controlling a subject's access to an object is fundamentally a security
kernel. So a padlock, a door badge system, a login mechanism on a computer system,
a operating system controlling access to components with the operating system,
a hypervisor controlling which virtual machines can connect to which of the underlying
physical hardware. All of these are fundamentally security kernels.
And the RMZ and the implementation of which the security kernel has to demonstrate
three properties to be a good security kernel. First, completeness. And this is about not being
able to bypass the rules. The subject should not be able to bypass and directly access an object
and bypass the mediation. So completeness impossible to bypass. Isolation, the rules are
tamper proof that can only be changed modified by an authorized individual. And verifiability.
How do you verify that this security kernel is actually working correctly, typically by logging
and monitoring the activity that's occurring, which subjects are getting to access to which
objects and which circumstances. And the final piece that we'll talk about here is the tcb.
And this is where we'll spend a minute here because there's often questions on the tcb and it
often confuses people a little bit. So here's the perfect definition of the tcb. It's the
totality of protection mechanisms within an architecture. So what does that actually mean?
Let's start with the word totality. What does totality mean? It means all everything, the assembly,
the collection, all of the components. So here's a really big hint for the exam. If you see anything
that says any word that means all the collection, the assembly, the everything related to the
protection mechanisms, that is the tcb. So it's all of the mechanisms that are responsible for
protecting a system. Think of it this way. Picture any type of architecture. Let's take a laptop
as an example. You might be sitting in front of one right now. Your laptop is going to have all
starts of components in it. You're going to have a CPU ram. You're going to have a hard drive.
You're going to have USB ports. You're going to have an operating system and all sorts of
applications and firmware. These are all the components within the architecture.
Some of those components are responsible for the security of a system. Things like your anti-malware
software, your security kernels, your host-based firewall. So the tcb is that subset of if you take
all of the components, it's the subset that are responsible for security. That is the tcb.
And so when we say you know what can make up the tcb, it's anything that is responsible for
security. Could be hardware, could be firmware, could be software, could be processes.
So that's the tcb. And the next few modules will start to talk through a bunch of different
components that we have within modern computing systems. And some of these components are in fact
security kernels and some of them are components within the tcb.